المخابرات البريطانية التي تقولها تظهر أن
روسيا تخشى أن تتمكن أوكرانيا من تحقيق
اختراق كبير، فهم
يبنون نظامًا واسعًا من
الخنادق في الجنوب، أخبرنا بما تراه، نعم،
لقد كانت
شبكة دوغ غير عادية، ربما وفقًا
لتقرير المخابرات البريطانية هذا  أكبر ما
رأيناه منذ الحرب العالمية الثانية عبر
المنطقة الجنوبية من زاباريسيا التي قادناها على
طول الجانب الأوكراني منها
لعدد لا بأس به من الأسابيع الماضية هنا غالبًا ما تكون هذه
خنادق عميقة يتبعها
ضفة رملية كبيرة مدعومة
بأسلاك شائكة  ثم هذه
القطع الخرسانية ذات شكل أسنان التنين
والتي تشكل سلسلة معقدة من
الدفاعات التي لا يمكن التغلب عليها باستخدام الأسلحة الحديثة
والمتفجرات والصواريخ المستهدفة
على الإطلاق، ولكنها بالتأكيد تمثل
تحديًا كبيرًا في
ذهن القوات الأوكرانية كما هي على
الأرجح.  في الأيام المقبلة، إن لم يكن
بالفعل في الأيام التالية، نبدأ
الهجوم المضاد في هذه المناطق، فنحن
ببساطة لا نعرف التفاصيل الكاملة
لخطتهم لنكون صادقين وما إذا كان من
المحتمل أن تلعب دورًا في ذلك، كان هناك
نقص غير عادي في مقاطع الفيديو من
الجيش الأوكراني  خلال الأسابيع الماضية
كانوا ينشرون عادةً من الأمام ولكن أولئك الذين
رأيناهم تحدثوا عن
الطين الذي يبطئ قدرتهم على التحرك
في ساحة المعركة أو بصراحة
سيتم الإعلان عن ذلك ولكننا سمعنا أيضًا
من السفير الأوكراني لدى
المملكة المتحدة ذلك  في الحقيقة هذا
الطقس السيئ يلعب دورًا لكن صني في
يوم ريني وفي اليوم التالي كل هذا يلعب في
القضية الأوسع هنا جيك ونحن
بالطبع نسمع أيضًا أه من جميع أنحاء
مدينة باكموت رمزية للغاية أه
أن القوات الروسية هناك تعرب عن
مخاوفها  حول نقص
القذائف المدفعية واحتمالية أن ذلك قد
يعني أنه يتعين عليهم البدء في سحب
جيك نيك، نسمع أيضًا عن
زيادة الهجمات وأعمال التخريب في
المناطق المحتلة في الجنوب، أخبرنا
عن ذلك
نعم بالتأكيد بناء هذا
الترقب الأوسع لـ  الهجوم المضاد
عبارة عن عدد من الهجمات التي قد
تشير إليها في المناطق المحتلة خلف
خطوط العدو وخاصة في قطب ميليتا،
وهي مدينة مستهدفة رئيسية لتحرير أوكرانيا
في الأسابيع المقبلة، سمعنا منذ بضعة أيام
عن مسؤول شرطة هناك
كان يعمل  بالنسبة
لقوات الاحتلال الروسية فقد قُتل
بحسب مصادر هناك وفي الساعات الأخيرة
أو نحو ذلك سمعنا عن محاولة أخرى
أه استهداف مسؤول يعمل لصالح
القوات الروسية المحتلة هناك
وفوق ذلك أيضاً الآن عدد من
الانفجارات  في استهداف منشآت السكك الحديدية
في تلك المنطقة، ربما كان أحدها عبارة عن
عبوة ناسفة بدائية الصنع،
اقتراحات
بانفجار محتمل آخر اليوم فقط بشكل متزايد ونحن
نتجه إلى ما يعتقد الكثيرون أنه الآن
بداية
الهجوم المضاد لأوكرانيا، وهو شيء كانوا
واضحين تمامًا أنهم سيفعلونه  ولم نعلن
أننا نشهد المزيد من التخريب
لأهداف داخل المناطق المحتلة جاك